in other 4 news Iran is pushing back
against new sanctions imposed by the
Trump administration on 18 individuals
and groups the country's Foreign
Minister Javad Zarif says the Trump
administration's rhetoric could
jeopardize a landmark nuclear agreement
he spoke yesterday with our Margaret
Brennan about the relations with the US
and the detention of two Iranian
Americans eighty-year-old vikarna mozzie
has been held for more than a year his
son 46 year old sciama quaza rested in
October 2015 on charges of collaborating
with a foreign government Margaret
Brennan is at the State Department with
more Margaret good morning good morning
well there are at least three Americans
currently detained in Iran and that
country's top diplomat told me it's not
helping already tense relations but
Karin namazi an American citizen he's in
his 80s he's in failing health why not
release him as a solitary ingestion he's
not behind bars but he is not free to
leave the country and as I said the
house the executive and this is what I'm
told the executive branch of the
government does not have control over
judicial decisions u.s. citizens see
onic namazi and his father Bakr had been
detained inside the notorious Evin
prison for nearly two years
no mozzies attorney in the White House
refuted Minister Zarif's account as
quote patently false a trump
administration official told CBS News
that both men have received especially
severe treatment probably due to their
American citizenship and accused the
reef of being either ignorant or
attempting to deceive Zarif said US
authorities unfairly treat Aronian
nationals the u.s. is basically
arresting or asking for the arrest of
Iranian Nationals all over the world he
also questioned why President Trump
seized Iran's rival Saudi Arabia as a
key ally whose nationals were involved
in 9/11 where there is single Iranian in
every act of terrorism that has been
committed against Americans on the US
soil since 2001
and if the answer is no then they'll see
that this policy that has been adopted
by the President of the United States is
an affront not only to Iranians but to
sensible human beings the Trump
administration's heated rhetoric and
recent sanctions on Iran are aimed in
Zarif's view at undermining the Obama
era deal to freeze Iran's nuclear
program it's one of the worst deals I've
ever witnessed
president Trump was reluctant to certify
that Tehran is living up to what he
calls a bad deal United States has been
in defiance of both letter and spirit of
the nuclear D does that mean it Ron's
going to walk away no because there are
procedures that are written into the
deal it's interesting for everybody to
understand that this deal was not based
on trust this deal was based on mutual
mistrust Zarif said these recent
sanctions are meant to poison the
atmosphere and ultimately even sink the
deal Nora the Trump administration is
still crafting its Iran policy and for
now says they'll stick to a strict
interpretation of the agreement
important interview Margaret thank you
so much interesting to hear that that
the deal was built on distrust and not
trust stress or vis Reagan used to say
trust but verify yes